[musique]
Repo de nombreux insulaires au cou d'ici le samedi 11 mars
Vers 20 heures
L'envoi de l'unité 1 et de l'unité 2 ensemble prend 17 minutes dans une pièce séparée.
personnel de la coopérative agricole
J'étais à l'usine le jour du banquet
Tout d'abord, il est petit après le passage des passants
Il y avait Matsunami à l'endroit où s'est produit le tremblement de terre
En raison de l'impact du tsunami
En raison de la perte de fiscalité, le pouvoir de façonner les 1ère et 2ème unités a été perdu.
C'est pourquoi je suis candidat à Matsushomai
Il est tombé, donc le son était plus fort que la dernière fois
Merci pour votre état
En service à l'époque
Je pensais que c'était un vrai troll alors j'ai utilisé une lampe de poche, etc.
Quant à l'arme qui peut être confirmée, elle est à portée de main
On dit qu'il a frappé un maximum de 86 avec son équipement.
Ouais
[musique]
Feuille de route en décembre dernier
Centrale nucléaire de Fukushima Daiichi
Il y a eu une révision de la feuille de route pour le déclassement
Je l'ai mentionné plus tôt
Nous travaillerons sur des choses telles que la réduction supplémentaire de la production d'eau de source.
Aussi
Situé à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de confinement du réacteur
Nous procédons au travail de préparation pour retirer ces choses dans l'ordre.
je vais venir